ANNOUNCED IT'S LAUNCHING A
EMBATTLED FLORIDPU BEFORE
ETZ IS SUPPOSED TO GIV ANTICIPA
AT THE DORAL TRUMP HOTEL IN
O CNS RANDI KAYE WHO HAS
THE VERY LAT orter: CONGRESSMAN
GAETZ TAKES THE STAGD OF SUSONE
PARTY CALLFOM WHY DOES ADAM KI
THINK HE SHOULD DO?
GASEE NIGHNMO
TRANSACTIONS IN MA
00 TO HIS FRIEND JOE A FORMEMIL.
THCORDING TO
TOTALING SAME AMOUNT.  SPAN,USEM
W OUREN PAYMENTS
HO OUTUP T TO THREE YOUNG
WOMEN ARYOUNG. AND ALL OF THESE
>> MEA?>> WELL, ONETURNEDX THAT.
>>ter: CNN HASN'T
INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRMED THIS
USFROMZ HAS DEEDHE MONEY WAS
DO
>> IT IS AE .
>> Reporter: TOOK TO THEAMAS
AND WHETHER WOMED TO
CONGRESSMAN AN WIT
THAT IS A POTEIAL WS WHIIR REPO
GAZ R PAID FOREXH
BH BLARING
LIT SEX TRAFFICKING
HAS NO INTA GENERAL
FIG NSENSUAL RELATIONSHIPS  A
IT'S UNCLEAR WT GREENBURY
E AND GAETZ WERE GOOD
FR>> HE'S UNUEUAorter: GENG HE'T
INVESTIGATORS.
S HEE ANYTHING TO
WORRY ABOUT?SK TT INTO
THE MINDF MA GAETZ?
I'M SURE MATOTG VERY COMFORTABL.
SEPARATE FROM THE ALLEGATIONS O"
IS ALSO REPORTIGATORS
HAVE BEEN E IN ANEFLORIDA LOBBY
ARRANGING A SO-CALLESH
CANDIDATE IN A STATE SLAST YN V
ALLY'S OPPONENT.
THEY CAUTIONHAT ASPECT OF E
INQUIRY IN ITS STAGES.Z DID NOT
"TIMES'" REQUE FOR COMMENTING T
MATT GAETZ WANO DA YOUR
MORE DETAIL ON THE H
INVESTIGATION.
THEY'VE LAUNCHED TWO, ON
CONGREMA GAETZ A
TO OF NEW ,
POTENTIALL
GAETZ FOR SEXUALUCT,
ILLICIT DRUG USE, CONVERTING
CAMPAIGN FUNDS TO PERSONAL USE
AND POSSLEE OF A
BRIBE AS FAR AS M REED GOES,
ALLEGAON SEXUAL
MISCON.
NOW, GAETZ'S OFFICD RESPOND
TOS LATEST HOUSE ETHS COMME NG
N, THESELEGATIONS ARE BLATANTLY.
THEY HAVE NOT BEENATY LI T
PUT THEIR ME
WHEN HE TAKES THE STAGE HERE
THE  SMI A7:00. TOGH
HE ADDRESSES THAT D ANNG
RANDI, JOINED BY C P
D
DI
DICT CHALIAN.
HOW DO YOU EXPECT GAETZ WILL
INVGAETHICS COMMITTEE WHEN HE
SPEAKSR NI
>> WELL, I'M SURE IF HE'
ADDRESS TH MAYBE WEAR IT AS BAD
IF YOU'VE SEEN HIS RES, WOLF, H
PULLING FROM THE TRUMP PLAY BOOK
OF DEALING WITH CONTROVERSY AND
OBVIOUSLY, HE'S DENYIN
EVER BLAMINGCAL OPPONENTS, BLAMG
THG
ZERO RESPONSIBILITLEDGIN
THIS
T GOOD FAIT       AETZ HAS BIY G
PROBLEM FOR MA.
Y WHATD
ON.
G ON GAETZ TO S THE ICISI TAKE I
I MEAN, THSI
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE AND TS P
OUT OFS KIND OW ER
CRISIS MANAGEMEND BY TRU  EEC N
O ONE IN WNGTON LONG SER
TETONEAR
MATT GAETZA 10POLE
HE'S SPEAKINGAT THAT CONFERENCN
S YOU,
EV NEED TO KNO
ABOUT HOW MUCH OR HOW LITTLE
SIDE ABANDONINGNCER ACTUA
HIM, PERHAPS IN THVIOR
ALLEGATIONS PLAY THEMSELVES OUT.
HOUSE SPEAKER JOHN BOE AN
EXPLORING THIS RIFT IN
THE PU AND
SC B
STE  CBS ABOUW
REPUBL LTE T CAL
MEMBERS POLITICAL TERRORISTS.
>>, JIM JORDAN ESPECIALLY.
NEVER PUT ANYTHING TOGETHER. WH?
>> AS YOU NOTED, AT
DE PARTY
BUT JOHN BOEHNER IS ON THE
SPEAKING AT,JORIE TAYLOR THERINL
GREEN.
AT SORT OF ACTIV F THE GROUP THD
THE JANUARY RACTU HAVE HIGH DOL
INAGTHE
FORMER PRESIDENT THIS WED
AND A LOT OF 202
PRESIDENTIALOPS SHOULD MPUN UP S
DO A PRETTY
GR, 0 DA
PRESIDENCY OR NEARINAT ON PU PA.
SO JOHR IS